most popular television characters get
the close-up treatment throughout the
course of a TV series but there are a
few fan favorites whose faces we never
get to see let's take a look or at least
have a listen at some faceless TV
characters whose still managed to make a
lasting impression Wilson on home
improvement Wilson what are you doing
I'm just testing my maracas usually when
I have mine tested the doctor makes me
turn my head and cough Tim Taylor's
trusty next to a neighbor on home
improvement was always futzing around in
his backyard improbably named Wilson W
Wilson the good-natured goof inspired
some of the show's most groan inducing
jokes during the course of the show
Wilson's face was always partially
concealed usually behind a fence I
couldn't sleep so I thought I'd come out
and squeeze my apples the character was
reportedly inspired by ten Alan's
real-life neighbor growing up when he
was still too short to see over the
fence and catch a glimpse at his full
face after hiding from audiences for
eight seasons actor Earl Hindman finally
revealed his face at the final curtain
call Maris crane on Frasier I'm supposed
to ask Maris to spend an evening with a
baseball player I just asked her to rub
my shoulders
Niles cranes former wife Maris wasn't
supposed to be concealed from Frasier
viewers forever but the character's
description quickly became too bizarre
to cast generally pale skeletal tiny and
altogether too strange to be human
before later becoming morbidly obese
executive producers Peter Casey and
David Lee explained in a season 2 DVD
extra with some of the things that have
been written about her in scripts I
don't know if we could ever find anybody
that would match all those things in the
season 5 episode voyage of the Damned
audiences did get to see a shadow of
Maris behind a shower curtain
[Music]
we wonder if david Hyde Pierce is still
waiting for that say me Maris spin off
when we go off the air whenever it is
she'll probably have her own show mrs.
Wolowitz on The Big Bang Theory
[Music]
here's a crazy idea
Howard Wolowitz's elusive mother on the
Big Bang Theory was voiced by the late
actress Carol Ann Susi
would you can totally hear in her season
5 appearance in Grey's Anatomy no she's
the mean one I don't want her Debbie
Wolowitz is described as a large woman
with a mustache and curly black hair but
that wasn't in keeping with the
appearance of the actress who voiced her
in Big Bang Theory season 5 finale we do
briefly see mrs. Wolowitz in an overhead
shot
we also catch a very brief glimpse of
her in the season 15 episode the spoiler
alert segmentation my mom died when
Carol Ann Susi sadly passed in 2014
writers decided Howard's mother would
die to still her memory lives on up lien
a kid guy on friends huh but ugly naked
guy looks ugly still we never learned
the real name of ugly naked guy on
friends but we certainly get to know him
I'm sorry I I can't help but notice that
you're naked
in a season 3 episode the gang even
pokes their bizarre nudists neighbor
with a rubber banded batch of chopsticks
because they think he's dead in another
season 3 episode we learned via
flashback that ugly naked guy had a very
different nickname three years earlier
the actor who played ugly naked guy
remained a pop-culture mystery for
decades until HuffPo writer Todd Van Lou
Lane cracked the case in 2016
meet the man the myth the legend actor
john Halcon he says it took him a while
to come forward because he was keeping
it mellow Plus Warner Brothers
reportedly wanted everybody to guess who
had played the role that's so ugly naked
guy george steinbrenner on Seinfeld
alright let's see what our way up
tonight Donna it's ham and cheese again
I got the fancy mustard it's rare for a
scripted sitcom to feature an impression
of a real public figure so when George
Costanza wound up working for Yankees
guru George Steinbrenner on Seinfeld the
approach was simple they only showed
Steinbrenner from behind with actor Lee
Behr appearing as the back of his head
and creator Larry David voicing the role
the real Steinbrenner loved the schtick
so much he agreed to tape a cameo as
himself that cameo never aired but his
scenes eventually made their way onto a
Seinfeld DVD
wait a minute young lady what's this
about singles tables I don't sit at
singles tables singles tables are for
losers now let's compare and contrast
well I'm gonna say it again I'll say it
again I haven't had a pebble since I was
18 and I don't care if you believe me or
not and how's this no fire isn't it
uncanny